[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à sept autres
éditions dc espace autochtone en direct
on ne s'était pas vue pendant les deux
dernières semaines je pense alors retour
sur le plateau pour parler cette semaine
du dépôt du rapport de la commission via
je vous présente tout de suite donc les
personnes qui sont autour de cette table
on commence avec isabelle isabelle
picard longs jours de la nation wendat
toujours un plaisir chaque semaine de
vous retrouver un autre picard qui lui
est de la nation innu ghislain picard
chef de l'apnql l'assemblée des
premières nations québec-labrador
bonjour un coin
et puis michel rouleau c'est une
nouvelle invitée sur notre plateau
bienvenue parmi nous madame rouleau
vous êtes métissé ojibway on dit comme
ça vous êtes productrice et vous avez
fondé une maison de production qui
s'appelle ou à vannes oc
vous avez été impliqués tout au long de
votre carrière auprès des femmes
autochtones alors on peut rappeler entre
autres que vous avez été directrice du
centre d'amitié autochtone de senneterre
pendant plusieurs années à sa fondation
quelques années il ya très très
longtemps et c'est important de rappeler
que vous avez été président de
l'association des femmes autochtones du
québec de 1987 à 1992 commissaire la
commission des droits de la personne et
de la jeunesse à québec où si du québec
en fait oui voilà donc et puis vous avez
témoignés autant monsieur picard que
madame rouleau à la commission vient
pendant pendant les différentes
audiences donc ça va être intéressant de
vous entendre à ce sujet là aussi
maintenant on va commencer par faire une
mise en contexte
donc on va rappeler que ce qui a mené à
la commission vient c'est un reportage
d'ailleurs de radio canada qui a révélé
des inconduites grave de la part des
policiers de val d'or donc ça a été
révélé ça en 2015
ensuite y'a des organismes qui ont
demandé qui ont réclamé une commission
denquête la commission denquête elle est
née elle a commencé ses travaux en juin
17 on l'appelle la commission circle sur
les relations entre les autochtones et
certains services publics du québec donc
cer paiement fait on l'appelle la
commission vient du nom de celui qui la
préside c'est l'ex juge à la retraite
jacques vient alors la commission
maintenant c'est terminé
le rapport final a été rendu après deux
ans et quatre mois
donc le rapport qui a été dévoilé après
38 semaines d'audience à valdes à
montréal québec
what mak mani-utenam mais cynique ou
deux jours avec écoute joie qu et
quelque 1300 documents déposés en preuve
il me semble un poisson de nier la
discrimination systémique dont sont
victimes les membres des premières
nations et les inuit dans leurs
relations avec les services publics
ayant fait l'objet de l'enquêté par
discrimination systémique
j'entends la définition qu'en font des
tribunaux c'est à dire une
discrimination à la fois directs et
indirects qui a pour caractéristique
d'être largement répandue voir
institutionnalisée dans les politiques
les pratiques et les cultures ayant
cours une discrimination qui peut
entraver le parcours d'un individu tout
au long de sa vie et même avoir des
effets négatifs sur plusieurs
générations donc problème ne va pas
toujours dis donc ça c'était un extrait
parce qu'évidemment à son allocution a
été beaucoup plus longue
ce qu'a dit le juge vient maintenant
c'est que la balle était dans le camp du
gouvernement du gouvernement du québec
est donc le premier appel à l'action
c'était la demande d' excuses ce qui a
été fait mercredi on va l'écouter
les femmes à tomtom sont celles qui ont
subi large pas des préjudices décrits
dans le rapport de la commission
l'état québécois n'en fait pas assez et
cette situation est indigne de la
société québécoise
en conséquence j'offre aux membres des
premières nations et aux inuits du
québec
les excuses les plus sincères de
l'ensemble de l'état québécois
l'état québécois manqué à son devoir
envers vous il vous demande aujourd'hui
pardon voilà françois legault premier
ministre du québec à leur première
question acceptez vous les excuses de
l'état québécois qui envie de commencer
monsieur picard bouteille
ma tête est super plein lors de toutes
sortes d'émotions de réactions
d'analystes depuis la dernière semaine
depuis que le rapport a été rendu public
mais je voudrais d'abord en cette
journée spéciale aujourd'hui le 4
octobre
on a ri les femmes à travers le pays et
amateurs tonnes à travers le pays jouit
les autochtones parce que ces journées
de veiller ensemble de nos communautés a
d'ailleurs est en marche c'est ça je dis
tout de suite là il ya une vigile qui
commence à 13h justement à val d'or
entre autres des faits commis dans le
jeu mais surtout maçonné ce qu'il fait
là parce que c'est une façon de se
rassembler autour d'un secteur
j'appellerai sow préoccupation parce qu
on est loin encore des solutions magris
s'est passé depuis des 72 dernières
heures et
je regarde un peu le premier geste qui
est posée suite au rapport du
commissaire vient les excuses tout le
monde zéro cas c'est la partie la plus
facile
et peut-être que mein à la lecture de ce
que j'ai j'ai vu que on a sans doute et
en hissant d'italie je plaide coupable
on est sans doute allé dans un excès de
complaisance par rapport au fait qu' il
ya des chocs et à l'eau qui ont applaudi
les paroles prononcées par le premier
ministre et les partis d'opposition
également mais ça on va vivre avec ça je
pense que ce qui est important
aujourd'hui lors c'est que vous savez
les excuses tout le monde conviendra que
c'est la partie la plus facile et c'est
un peu pour ce que j'en sais un peu
comme le phénomène de la violence en
cinquième à lens on passe à l'acte on
s'excuse turcomane
c'est un peu c'est un peu ce que je vois
ici et pour moi bon il faudra être
extrêmement extrêmement vigilants quant
à la suite des choses
et lorsque je sens depuis 24 heures
trente six ans c'est une espèce de
tentative de diversion et qui consiste
vraiment l'eau à nous renvoyer la balle
comme premières nations comme si on
avait l'ultime responsabilité les choses
et savoir excuser de façon trop
importante les réformes structurelles
importantes et majeur qui nous pousse au
sein du gouvernement est stoppé et juste
parce que il ya la question tout le
monde conviendra cas la question des
femmes autochtones et la violence qu'ils
ont subis a été négligée sinon on n'en
n'a fait aucune mention
et en même temps mais je pense que les
besoins les attentes de nos populations
par rapport une réforme sérieuse de
l'appareil gouvernemental est fondée
donc on est un peu pris entre ces deux
ces deux responsabilités là de rappeler
le gouvernement et toutes ces nations
alors par rapport au traitement des
femmes sont autant et aussi notre
responsabilité de voir à ce que le
processus qui doit le dire qui peut
partir des paroles du gouvernement et
des partis promotion que le processus
s'enclenche on est là c'est super ex ion
des dirigeants des communautés
finalement alors je vous vois abondé
dans le même sens madame rouleau en
définitive même mois la même chose des
excuces et c'est aussi quelqu'un
s'excuse si oui mais ne leur fait plus
exotiques et qu'est ce que tu vas faire
pour pour changer les choses avancer
seule la question fondamentale mais
aussi mais je pense que les excuses j'ai
trouvé qu'elles sont arrivées tellement
rapidement ou sur lendemain du dépôt du
rapport
on s'excuse au nom du peuple québécois
je me demande bien ce qu'ils ont eu le
temps de faire une réflexion avant de
s'excuser
on s'excuse pas juste pour la forme mais
depuis le temps que je suis dans ces
univers là je pense que j'ai perdu pas
mal de naïveté et on comprend très bien
que c'est un gouvernement qui est élu
depuis un an qui veut absolument prouver
à tout prix qu'ils sont efficaces alors
à une manoeuvre politique là dessus moi
je pense
voyez on agit on fait des excuses tout
de suite on va prendre au sérieux n'a
pas c'est une recommandation sur 142
alors on est on est très très loin de
deux choses concrètes peuvent tout à
fait d'accord il ya des choses qu'il
faut changer
il ne peut pas
nous dire que tout va bien à lui tout à
coup on vienne prendre conscience des
injustices mais alors à ce sujet là
isabelle évidemment vous êtes sur le
plateau chaque semaine mais vous écrivez
aussi des chroniques pour espace
autochtone est la vôtre est très bien
titré aujourd'hui je m'excuse mais oui
exactement le premier appel à l'action
c'est les excuses le deuxième c'est la
reconnaissance et la mise en action de
la déclaration des droits des peuples
autochtones et l'a déjà hier monsieur
legault dit oh oh attendez
oui mais non faut pas que ça touche à
l'intégrité de l'état québécois faut pas
que ça dérange trop nos affaires faut
pas que ça brasse trop les cartes ya
quelque chose leur mois il déjà les
autochtones sont oubliés absolument il
ya quelque chose là qui est venu me
dérange et je veux dire comme je le dis
dans mon texte matin la côte est les
abruptes elle est longue
quel veinard du à monter mais si au
deuxième coup de [ __ ] déjà on
s'essouffle qui ont dit ah ben là c'est
ça demande trop à l'état québécois on va
laisser faire moi c'est le message que
j'ai reçu et je trouve ça
un peu de joie sur wii peu rassurants
alors vous êtes là aujourd'hui pour
expliquer à monsieur legault sur quoi il
doit agir et comment il doit le faire et
à quelle vitesse il doit le faire par
quoi on doit commencer parce que c'est
quand même 140 et une recommandation il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de travail
est ce qu'on peut déjà tout mettre sur
la table et commençait déjà à toutes
appliquées qu est ce qui est important
qu est ce qui est vital qu'est ce qui
est crucial à ce moment ci beauté si la
parole mais d'aller content d'avoir
cette tribune aujourd'hui avec un michel
et isabelle puis je pense qu on présente
à nous trois sans doute une réflexion
qui est encore mature sur doumbia oui on
se rappellera qu'il ya quarante ans que
c'était l'époque de rené lévesque
c'était l'époque du sag maille qui
étaient chargés d'entretenir la relation
entre nos nations et le gouvernement du
québec de l'époque sous rené lévesque et
on constate que ce rouleau extrêmement
changé depuis et ce n'est plus du tout
la même chose et c'est pour ça qu'on
essaie sur la nécessité qu on puisse
engager chaque chaque ministère ou sein
du gouvernement du québec parce que ce
qu'on constate depuis un an c'est quand
on a passé beaucoup de temps à essayer
de faire deux autochtones 5 puis on a de
la misère à percer à bersée à se faire
entendre
d'abord à se faire écouter aussi et on
est un petit peu depuis un an n'ont pas
ce qu'on dit
et vous allez tout croche c'est pas
comme ça que ça doit se passer temps et
donc s'il doit y avoir un point de
départ a cessé c'est justement ça
comment on définit ce point de départ
par où ça doit commencer
mais une chose à laquelle je vais me
permettre d'insister que c'est pas c'est
de ne pas laisser la coordination la
démarche au niveau au niveau
administratif
il faut que la partie politique qu'on
soit vraiment bien assis sur des bases
solides sur des principes on est capable
de convenir de principes qui nous sont
communs gouvernementales et du côté
autochtone et convenir du car finalement
il doit régir tout ça parce que sans ça
on attend du monsieur legault dire bon
ok je pense que les autochtones disent
qu'ils veulent pas du protecteur du
citoyen
donc encore une fois et une autre
tentative de diversion pour essayer de
ramener pète un peu plus loin dans cette
réforme nécessaire
je pense qu'ils vont être extrêmement
extrêmement vigilant par rapport aux
prochains au prochain geste
cette fameuse rencontre du secteur
notamment puis quand même on est au
québec mais il ya une grande diversité
chez nous aussi donc il faudra tenir
compte et je pense que la participation
de isabelle dans cette analyse ces
observations étaient extrêmement
importante aussi parce que les jeunes
aussi sont extrêmement inquiets de la
suite des choses et moi je suis je suis
connecté aux réseaux sociaux puissent
jeu lille à cette inquiétude oui
d'ailleurs comment vous la préparez la
suite parce que c'est ça il ya cette
rencontre le 17 octobre
mais qu'est ce qui est planifié cette
journée là les organisations autochtones
vont être là le gouvernement va être là
les chefs autochtones vont être là il y
aura beaucoup de monde autour de la
table à ce qui est plaint déjà de prévu
ben oui tout ce que je peux dire là
dessus un mois j'ai pas eu droit la
liste d'invités
voir la liste et on comprend qu'il ya
des chefs qui ont été invités est ce que
d'autres personnes qui me l'ont été
aussi
mais si je dire dans les prochains dix
jours on n'a pas mis au clair comment ça
doit se passer bien ça risque d'être une
tour de babel venu le 17 octobre
je pense que ça peut être bon prétexte
pour dégager le gouvernement aussi c'est
ce que je trouve inquiétant
moi je pense que tout de suite le 17
octobre ça fait pas de sens que ce soit
je sais pas comment ça s'organise ce que
j'entends de la part de ghislain sait
que c'est le gouvernement qui organise
le truc je dois déjà ça fait pas de sens
si on veut travailler ensemble le mot
ensemble est revenue tellement souvent
dans le discours de monsieur legault oui
on doit commencer le oui arrive en la
rampe me dis qu'ils ont peu et comment
on fait les choses pour ados comme celle
à wii dont vous n'êtes pas impliqué dans
cette organisation de base là bas si on
suit au par oui ça me mine est à une
partie de la position aussi c'est que ça
doit se faire en sang mais encore là
comment on s'engage eu jeudi en commun
ça aussi c'est important ça peut pas
faire de n'importe quelle façon c'est
pas une partie qui prime sur l'au delà
c'est important de s'entendre sur les
basses comment comment ça se passe tout
ça mais écoutez comme le dit isabelle b
7 octobre c'est demain cependant nuit je
mens qui font évidemment bien bien se
préparer
mais en même temps il ya tout l'aspect
politique là d abord nous le rappeler
bon depuis trente six ans et une autre
question qui revient sur des lits la
question de la déclaration deuxième et
troisième recommandation du rapport bien
oui et pour moi c'est extrêmement
important
d'un côté même
j'entendais le premier disque dur bon je
vois le parti québécois que le parti
québécois est d'accord avec moi j'étais
à l'assemblée nationale avec pauline
marois en 2010 le parti québécois qui
disait on appuie la déclaration de l'onu
donc on avance plus on recule selon qui
on est et où on est alors on va revient
à la commission vient ce que vous aviez
déclaré à l'époque lorsque vous avez été
invité donc à parler
michel rouleau vous vous étiez à
l'époque intéressé principalement aux
femmes un oui ou des films muets étant
une femme puisse sachant que cette
commission là est issu de tout ce qui
c'était passé à val d'or puis pas
particulièrement jeu on a tous compris
lequel la commission
elle n'était pas là pour réexaminer les
corps spécifiques julien prend la peine
de le rappeler qu'il ne pas refaire le
code criminel et tout ça mais ça va bien
au delà de sauce qui s'est passé à val
d'or wifi moi ma préoccupation ce dont
j'ai tenu à témoigner devant la
commission c'était ça parce que souvent
on en a vu du rapport 300
recommandations 400 recommandations et
là moi ma complainte si on veut à la
commission s'était j'espère que les la
question des femmes autochtones de mal
dans des problèmes avec les services
policiers ne sera pas noyé dans un océan
de recommandations et puis qu'il ya
aussi tout le monde je pense qu'ils
des premières nations a appuyé la
déclaration des nations unies l'ont des
noix les peuples autochtones
effectivement c c'est la base qui doit
déterminer justement comment nos
relations doivent s'effectuer la
déclaration à l'ancien on essaie de tout
régler le reste en faisant fi de ça on
fait des filles on met de côté le pied
ce qui devrait être la base de cela on
là tu as parfois sombre faire des
ententes sur différents services et
soyez heureux mais moi ma présentation
avait surtout porté sur la question
différemment toc toc je sais pas oui je
peux y revenir tout de suite mais c'est
là selon moi il manque une section dans
le rapport bien il manque une section je
les lui dans tous les sens là et je ne
suis pas la seule je pense qu isabelle
aux siens de fait la lecture mais si on
parle de des services publics des
relations et moi ce qui m'a un peu
blessé c'est ça c'est que le juge vient
branle à la peine dans son commentaire
de d'introduction dans sa lettre de
remercier les femmes wheeldon de vagues
à le premier ministre a remercié les
femmes autochtones tout le monde les
remercie comment sait-il qu'il ait zéro
recommandations pour leur venir en aide
et je parle pas non plus de 2 de
poursuivre les policy le jeu bande de
deux systèmes
une défaillance au niveau des relations
sérieuses et graves et ces femmes là où
vivent encore dans la peur aujourd'hui
elles vivent encore dans la part elles
vivent encore des représailles
alors il manque une fiction est ce que
les divers appels à l'action dans
chacune des catégories que ce soit les
services policiers les services sociaux
et cetera ne va pas finalement finir par
justement prendre en considération les
femmes parce que chacune de ces attaques
est à plat va venir
normalement les aider c'est ce qu'on
nous répond mais mais je me dis pourquoi
les avoir temps interpellé oui et c'est
plus que ça c'est pas oh ben ça va vous
venir parle parce que si on regarde la
saison des services policiers il ya très
peu de choses il ya toute la question du
soutien qu'on doit apporter davantage
aux corps policiers dans les communautés
autochtones est tout à fait justifiée
qui est nécessaire mais qu'en est il de
la sûreté du québec
qu'en est il de leurs relations avec les
autochtones et c'est connu à la grandeur
du québec s'est pas seulement val d'oise
et un problème au niveau des relations
puissent du polo qui sont tous des
méchants qui sont aidées mais il ya un
problème au niveau des relations comment
se fait il qu'on ne veut pas en parler
de son moi c'est ça ma question c'est on
n'en parle pas et tout le monde le dit à
l'époque à val-d'or l'observatrice
indépendante remettre fannie lafontaine
puis avait parlé de l'existence de
racisme systémique au sein des forces de
l'ordre alors encore là je me dis les
dirigeants policiers doivent au moins
reconnaître qu'un problème sinon comment
pourra-t-on trouver une solution oui et
cette relation déficiente là selon moi
je l'écoutais la commission vient tout
ce qui portait sur les services
policiers les services à la justice j'ai
écouté de a à z
et combien de fois il revenu l'aspect
l'importance de la formation des
policiers allochtone je comprends pas et
j'ai fait comme madame rouleau j'ai lu
et relu que j'ai dit non non j'en ai
manqué ça va d'ailleurs je voulais
c'était la base nissan y est pas donc
oui à des trucs indirect entre autres
prolonger le laps de temps possible pour
une plainte en déontologie donc la
portée d'un à trois 908 n'a pas éteint
dans we supporter les femmes mais tous
les autochtones dans leur processus de
plainte par une campagne d'information
de sensibilisation sapin dans mes yeux
pleins de choses direct que je ne vois
pas et c'est un le grand moment de ces
deux sera parle oui monsieur picard band
là dessus je suis d'abord heureux qu'on
en parle parce que
en dépit de la diversité chez nous je
pense que tout le monde converge vers le
même constat c'est que il y a
dans le rapport un chapitre avec des
bâches blanches et c'est justement ce
qui a donné lieu à la mise sur pied de
la commission les événements avant d'en
rappeler quelque chose parce que l'armée
lecture c'est ce que j'ai constaté puis
je pense qu'on je parlais de l'odieux
qui nous revient un peu trop souvent
puis c'est ce que le rapport dans ses
conclusions semblent confirmer encore
une fois parce que j'ai lu qu'ils
quelque chose qui est très dérangeant
pour moi parce que dans le rappel des
événements qui ont mené à la mise sur
pied de la commission il il ya quelque
chose dans le rapport qui est qui qui
qui est fautif c'est c'est pas exact de
rapporter que les premières nations les
organisations autochtones finalement ont
proposé la tenue d'une commission sur
les services publics
c'est à l'origine c'est parce qu'ils
avaient été demandés ce qu'invités
demandé l'origine c'est une commission
d'enquêté judiciaire pour aller aussi
loin qu'on ne pouvait pour relever ceux
rattachés aux événements qui ont permis
finalement la création de la commission
avec le résultat qu'on a aujourd'hui
quelque part on dit que oui le chantier
est extrêmement vaste
on est d'accord là dessus mais en même
temps le mandat est extrêmement limité
pour aller chercher jeudi le l'appui
finalement aux premières victimes les
femmes drôles donne et c'est pour cela
que nous dans nos recommandations le dit
et on vient frapper à votre porte comme
commission met de côté on sait qu à
personne parce qu'on sait que ce qu'on
cherche là on va l'obtenir ailleurs la
question de justice reconnaisse
reconnaissance qu'il ya des droits
humains qui ont été ben oui si c'est pas
ici qu'on va trouver son valet au niveau
international
donc mais ça c'est quelque chose qui
nous appartient mais pas entièrement sa
besoin d aide
des volontaires des femmes de tonnes
pour qu'on puisse déjà couvrir démarche
donc c'est pas terminé mais de toute
évidence lancée par la commission qui va
amener ses réponses l'onil gouvernement
d'ailleurs je suis d'accord et aussi une
chose par contre cc oui je pense que
c'est nécessaire d'aller au niveau des
droits et des noms internationaux mais
on sait que c'est des processus qui sont
extrêmement longs aussi je sais j'en ai
vécu ça avec la situation des femmes
autochtones a auparavant sur la question
du statut indien alors ça a pris des
années les années et les générations
alors là il ya des femmes qui sont à val
d'or qui ont peur de sortir ça se vit
aujourd'hui alors c'est très inquiétant
mais moi je pense qu'il ya une chose
dont les parents ont dit on veut mettre
fin aux rapports ce à dire au racisme
systémique
oui si on peut mettre fin au racisme
systémique s'attaquer aux structures
mais peut-être qu'on peut pas non plus
on peut pas mettre fin au racisme de
certains individus
par contre on peut les empêcher de se
cacher derrière un système qui les a
protégés jusqu'à maintenant alors je me
dis il faut élaborer des protocoles il
faut il faut élaborer des façons de
faire et de reddition des comptes non
c'est parce que quand on connaît la
situation et pour saab
moi je dis des policiers l'aca obéi à
des ordres
oui c'est pas en quelque chose qui est
qui qui est libre de leur décision
personnelle je veux dire izon des ddd
des formations spécifiques ils ont un
travail à faire qui est important dans
la société pour protéger les citoyens et
ils ont des ordres à suivre alors il
faut que les ordres viennent d'en haut
alors faut que les dirigeants c'est sa
première manche ne connaissent qu'un
problème et qui est un message clair de
la part des dirigeants qu'on ne tolère
plus des actes racistes on est dans nos
milieux
d'ailleurs vous l'aviez déclaré lors de
votre passage à la commission vous
disiez l'importance de ne pas permettre
aux personnes racistes et habité par des
préjugés d'être protégés par le système
ce que j'aimerais ajouter à ce que
michel gym tout à fait approprié
d'ailleurs parce que
une chose qu'une source que le rapport
ne mentionne pas si le mans justement
récession comme si on avait peur de se
rendre jusque là et ça me rappelle un
peu toute la période où on a fait du
lobby pour que la commission voit le
jour entre les événements 2015 et 2016
le 23 décembre cadeau de noël en 2016
quand le gouvernement a annoncé
finalement que la commission verrait le
jour
on s'est buté devant des obstacles
importants pour faire reconnaître
gouvernement que finalement oui et en os
du racisme et je passe le nommer l'on
sait sans doute les personnes physiques
sont plus en position de taille donc et
pour moi ça aussi c'est important parce
que le rapport est un peu je ne serai
pas jusque là je trouve ça regrettable
parce que si on parle de racisme on
parle beaucoup plus d'un problème qui
nous dresse pour responsabilisation
sociétale on connaît les limites du
gouvernement mais il ya aussi nous comme
société oui dans les rues à tous les
jours interpellée alors fait ce que dit
le rapport dans les appels à l'action
par exemple le numéro 20 réalisé en
collaboration que les autres les autorit
automne une campagne sociétale
d'informations sur les peuples
autochtones du québec leur histoire leur
diversité culturelle et les enjeux de
discrimination les affectant on parle
pas de racisme on ne nomme pas le mot
racisme mais on essaie par d'autres
moyens d'ouvrir l'esprit de la société
en général est-ce que c'est suffisant
d'entendre ça ben oui je je pense qu'on
aurait pu aller plus loin que son mais
si ça donne lieu à des
des initiatives ou des plans d'action
pour faire en sorte que le petit qui
jouent au hockey en fait seulement dans
un arrêt non en région oui qui se
produit qui se fait traiter de sauvages
ou deux cas oui cela oui si ça peu
contrit saubens je dis bravo
mais je parle de personnes qui l'aident
qu'ils vivent à tous les jours ben c'est
de soja car oui les gens rentrent 6
absolument on voit aussi l appel à
l'action numéro 23 et klur en
collaboration avec les autorités
autochtone a volé sur les premières
nations et les inuit du québec dans les
parcours de formation collégiale ou
universitaire menant une pratique
professionnelle
on parle de médecins travailleur social
avocats journalistes journalistes voilà
parlons des médias du rôle des médias
justement là dedans je pense que c'est
absolument nécessaire cet appel à
l'action là il est déjà tard pour le
faire selon moi il ya déjà des
universités aux canadairs vous vous les
connaissez qui oblige tous les étudiants
à n'importe quelle discipline de
baccalauréat
à suivre d'abord et avant tout un cours
autochtones sans wii pour rattraper un
peu ce qu'on n'a pas vu au secondaire
les programmes qui sont vraiment presque
inexistant en exil jusqu'en 1958 à
pression n'existe plus ou presque
pour moi ça m'apparaît nécessaire ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut faire
tout de suite on parler de racisme tout
à l'heure mais pour contrecarrer le
racisme
il ya une solution c'est de l'éducation
l'éducation sa part du primaire
secondaire collèges universités jimmy
j'enseigne un cours à l'université
introduction au monde autochtone
ce sont des allochtone qui sont là on
voit j'ai une centaine d'étudiants quand
même on voit de plus en plus d'intérêt
je pense que ça ça devrait être ouvert
toutes les universités devraient offrir
ce les cégeps est un must
il faut rattraper des décennies
finalement de désinformation de préjugés
il ya vraiment il ya vraiment une
méconnaissance de l'histoire c'est
fascinant
c'est comment les gens ne connaissent
pas l'histoire puis ne connaissent pas
justement les questions autochtones
encore moins c'est désolant qu'on soit
on est en 2019 les gens rarement sont
capables de nous nommer toutes les
différentes nations départ des premières
nations même au québec
ok il ya des balles ce qu'on n'a même
pas oui c'est urgent d'avoir ces bases
là au moins qu' il faut que la formation
à tous les niveaux jeunes au niveau
primaire font prendre
il faut et on n'a pas besoin de tout
comprendre dès le départ ça se fait
petit à petit et à long terme il faut
que ces institutions là ces
organismes-là qui donne ces formations
là on est les moyens dont est parce qu
une avidité dans la population
il ya eu il est toujours c'est toujours
il ya toujours le minimum il ya toujours
dans le petit groupe qui sont qui sont
bornés qui pense qu'on a les toupies qui
apprendront rien soit on n'y peut rien
puis on en a dans tous les milieux
jeunes hommes sont dans l'eau dans les
airs docteur nom ni poteau des génies
mais c'est le propre de l'humaniste
humain c'est vrai mais entre humains qui
veulent de moi une volonté qui veulent
se comprendre s'entraider y en a où ils
en ont on fait son effet sur toutes nos
vies faire ce genre de choses on veut un
rapprochement
ça commence vraiment j'en vois ça je me
dis c'est décourageant les font
heureusement on tourne est encore devant
un espèce de deux bouteilles à la mer
mais sur le terrain il ya des choses qui
chante c'est ce qui a encore du racisme
ccc intense encore nous on était à la
librairie d'ottawa il ya deux jours pour
présenter notre documentaire ce silence
qui tue et dans le documentaire on tente
de toutes ces questions là et puis avant
de partir le soir un de nos
protagonistes étaient dehors devant la
porte doute l appuyer sur la porte
happy ils textent est sur son cellulaire
oui il ya un agent de sécurité de la
ville pas de l'hôtel mais qui est venu
le
lui dire de circuler puis s'est éloigné
puis il entendu dire fuck un énième on
est là en train de parler de ça c'est ce
vide comme seul jabron dans le même sens
puis on al'avantage nous trop de de
travailler avec le monde des médias ou
l'avoir fait lopy je pense que c'est
utile d'avoir cette perspective là et tu
es un chapitre complet des appels à des
actions qui sont dirigés vers la
responsabilité des médias comme c'est le
cas pour la ccb comme si en vérité
conciliation oui oui et je pense que
c'était important de se rappeler parce
que un marge des excuses à l'assemblée
nationale il ya deux jours en même temps
il y avait un sondage qui avait tricoté
dans la région de l'abitibi et la
réponse était est ce que vous êtes
d'accord que le premier ministre
s'excuse auprès des autochtones je
formule la question comme celle gelé
comprise et il ya 64 % des gens qui
avaient dit non et donc on a énormément
de travail à faire nous mais aussi le
monde des médias pour pas pour vraiment
aller dans la substance je trouve ça
extrêmement important là c'est le petit
crâne de 30 secondes c'est une chose
mais on fait la démonstration lors qu'on
peut aller au fond des choses
lorsque le temps d'atteindre le permet
et je pense que c'est des fois un peu
trop facile à jeudi à l'actualité on la
comprend pas savoir très vite le média
sociaux mais en même temps je pense
qu'il y aurait moyen peut-être de donner
à l'art
alité des fois la triste réalité chez
nous les semences qu'il verra bien oui
parce que pendant longtemps on a été
absents les médias à part quelques
exceptions mais quand les téléromans les
séries télé que les gens écoutent au
québec et des autochtones la dent depuis
deux ans c'est 1,2 alors si les gens
étaient en contact avec le monde
autochtone quotidiennement
oui quand il écoute des émissions comme
tout ce qui se passe le soir est que les
gens suivent régulièrement
s'il y avait une présence autochtone qui
n'était pas nécessairement souligner à
gros traits là mais il y en a plein de
gens qui vivent en société non
autochtones qui sont là des gens qui
sont des métiers c'est qu'ils font
partie de la société pourquoi on n'a
jamais parlé de ces réalités là c'est
sûr c'est parce que les gens à qui les
écrit ces choses ne connaissent pas
laisser ça fait il faut aller partout
puis moi je me dis oui les journalistes
ont intérêt à apprendre davantage sur le
monde autochtone y en a qui s'y
connaissent plus que d'autres mais
justement faire quoi que ce soit non
plus nichlas et faut que tout le monde
sache quand il se passe quelque chose de
quoi on parle qui parle pourquoi je vais
oui les journalistes parce qu'on vit
souvent les médias on pense que c'est
les journalistes que yacine ali pas
seulement les journalistes c'est vos
patrons les patrons à eau qui prennent
des décisions dans leur bureau puis des
gens qu'on ne verra jamais plus qu'ils
ne se feront jamais reproché d'avoir
questionner mais les patrons que
font-ils que saft il eu et c'est eux qui
décident ce qu'on va voir à la
télévision
alors il faut qu'il ya une ouverture de
ce côté-là aussi faut qu'une prise de
conscience on peut plus ignorer cette
réalité d'aujourd'hui tout le monde le
dit
jugement le 10 le ccl s'il faut faire
des efforts de part et d'autre vraiment
vraiment je suis d'accord avec avec ce
que ghislain disait il faut on est
beaucoup dans la dans le commentaire
dans l'immédiat on est beaucoup dans le
haut de 2 minutes
on n'est pas beaucoup dans l'analyse
j'ai fait une autre juste faite à la
commission vient avec patrick lagacé qui
me posait la question et j'avais il me
restait 20 secondes pour répondre qu'est
ce que la discrimination systémique et
que ces 20 secondes par moment donné je
veux bien essayer mais il faut laisser
le temps il faut dire les choses si on
veut bien les comprendre et ça le met
dans l'immédiat doivent faire espace
autochtone le fait très bien mais c'est
un des seuls les autres les autres
médias majeurs doivent faire cet
espace-là donner du temps pour qu'on
puisse parler pourquoi opus comprend
mieux comprendre la réalité les anges
c'est ce que j'ai remarqué la journée du
lancement du rapport c'est que beaucoup
entrent dans l'émission j'ai écouté
c'était des animateurs non autochtone
avec des journalistes non autochtone qui
interviewait des experts journalistes
experts non autochtone alors on se ment
du sebou et tout le monde interprétée en
duo mais n'est pas n'est pas dessus
alors je pense que ce soit il ya un
besoin d'aller chercher des gens
davantage puis de 2,2 saisir pour
revenir à ce que ghislain disais tout à
l'heure sur le fait que les gens ne sont
n'était pas d'accord ou le sondage
disait que 65 % n'étaient pas d'accord
des excuses je pense qu'on peut
comprendre aussi
ils ne savent pas ils ne savent rien
alors je me dis si on raisonne peut-être
un peu peut simplement le 11 et ben il
s'excuserait pourquoi s'ils ne savent
pour savoir exactement je pense qu'il
faut qu'ils comprennent pourquoi ils
sosa bourillon du temps ça ne vient pas
dans une émission une demi-heure ou dans
un quinze minutes de discussion
c'est vraiment alors je pense qu'il faut
prendre très au sérieux la question de
la diffusion d'information la bonne
information aussi est il
la discussion là-dessus pignon notre
crainte moi ma crainte avec les femmes
avec qui j'ai parlé ce que l'on n'a pas
de sens bien là on va en entendre parler
lors du lancement du rapport la journée
des excuses puis après on n'entendra
plus jamais parler et c'est ce qui est
triste c'est ccma craintes et il faut
que ça continue il faut qu'on a une
place pour parler quelque part alors
comment doit-on faire de part et d'autre
pour continuer à en parler
que comptez vous faire de votre côté par
exemple et que doit faire les non
autochtones pour que ça ne sorte ça ne
s'oublie pas et on en pense souvent est
ce que ce ne soit pas table été comme
bien des rapports basse et je pense que
nous tous c'est ce jeu car comme société
il a le danger qui nous guette puis je
dis souvent son aile la poussière finit
toujours par tomber trop rapidement et
c'est c'est la responsabilité de nous
que nous avons de la garde et où elle
devrait être
et écouter ou de l'autre de notre
responsabilité je parle pour l'assemblée
des premières nations à présent donc qui
tous responsables d'équipés premièrement
politiques ont fait beaucoup d'à côté
aussi impôts essayer de ne pas refaire
une éducation qui est déficient par
rapport à notre réalité on organiser le
festival coups et devant l'assemblée
nationale pour une troisième année cette
année donc ça c'est des moments qui
permettent justement l'espèce de
rencontres nécessaires avec un r
majuscule dans un un cadre plus
convivial oui il n'y a pas de pression
qui sentit de la partie de groupe donc
donc sur ce aussi c'est important
en même temps ben on est parce que sur 1
100 catherine non la discrimination
votre celui-là d'ipo de la même façon
que si tu es à la tuque à trois-rivières
balle dans onze c'était donc pour nous
l'esprit de l'engagement avec les
gouvernements municipaux c'est aussi de
permettre qu'il y ait à franchement un
peu plus un peu plus positifs lors
entre nos communautés qualité qui les
environne donc ça aussi c'est important
et c'est ce type de geste là qui tantôt
oui politique mais aussi qui nous
permettent de le poser d'autres gestes
houssin il favorise le rapprochement
donc sauce on maintient le cap là dessus
mais c'est clair que il faut qu'il y ait
une compréhension mutuelle par rapport à
l'engagement que par rapport à l'ampleur
du chantier et on doit travailler
surtout monsieur le juge vient karl du
logement
tout le monde a tendance à penser ok ben
c'est par québec si le fédéral mais en
même temps c'est plus que cela c'est que
le logement je pense que on est rendu à
une étape où d'ailleurs le juge elle le
rappelle lui-même le principe de jardin
qui consiste à mettre de l'ordre dans
les conflits juridictionnelle ben ali ça
doit pas uniquement se porter sur les
enfants ouvert les enfants ça doit aller
plus haut si et je pense que l'on doit
avoir une discussion plus large sur les
responsabilités des uns et des autres
nous étudions aussi au nom également une
responsabilité mais je pense qu'on en a
maintenant s'il ya des endroit justement
pour établir ou refaire nos relations
je sais parler de l'événement quick
était quand même très très apprécié mais
je pense ça a été ça a été bien perçu
mais il y en a des événements qui se
produisent comme ça puis je pense que
justement des gens pour des gens non
autochtone qui s'intéresse je pense que
qu'aujourd'hui peuvent trouver des
endroits où il se passe des choses mais
pour être guidé par contre je pense je
sens un pourparlers en milieu urbain moi
j'ai dû du réseau des centres d'amitié
autochtones et 100 m cet automne on a
toujours fait ça tenter d'améliorer les
relations puis d'organiser des activités
d'inviter les gens ça se fait encore je
pense qu'il ya une dizaine de centres de
métier au québec
ils font des activités pour être
inclusif pour faire connaître leur
culture
alors puis on parle c'est peut-être ça
peut-être leur cliché mais les parois ou
aussi puis des paroles et des événements
pacifique ces événements festifs
ensemble c'est ça alors hissé son niveau
de la culture je pense que
définitivement la culture en nous tant
qu'on nous laisse parler prendre notre
place en maths importe là les
autochtones d'ailleurs seront présents
il y avait le gallate hayden cette
semaine à trois-rivières
je pense qu'avec des non autochtones de
plus en plus qui s'y présentent qui
viennent y faire un tour
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de personnes
notre à soi même si j'ai joué j'ai
quitté la soirée à mi chemin parce que
la semaine à l'extérieur et j'avais
d'autres engagements mais ça va pas eu
de rencontrer certaines personnes qui en
qu'ils énoncent des noms de panne je
suis parti de québec sort je trouve ça
extrêmement encourageants puis puis je
pense qu'on fait quand même une percée
mais ça c'est je passe des choses qui
méritent d'être dit oui d'être
publiciser par exemple la diski cette
année bon pour une première fois va
décerner un prix pour l'artiste
autochtone de nani sens et quelque chose
extrêmement important pour la société
québécoise les pour nous si oui qui je
pense qu'on vient fermer un peu cette
espèce de portes lot de barrière entre
ce que j'appellerais de soi l'étude lyon
et je pense que ça c'est gagnant doit y
en avoir plus de ces décisions là comme
ce que l'adisq en fait j'ai l'impression
que
j'ai une quarantaine d'années que j'ai
l'impression que tout ce que j'ai fait
depuis je suis petit c'est me battre
pour me faire entendre pour faire
entendre la voix autochtone en sa place
c'est fatiguant coup et c'est nous qui
organisons les palois c'est nous qui
organisons on aimerait ça des fois est
invité à voir un espace que ce soit pas
toujours dans la bataille on est content
qu'on les gangs ces petites batailles là
mais mon dieu que j'aimerais ça semble
que c'est fatigant l'on aime resta
justement passer à l'action qui a des
actions vraiment direct des solutions
tout de suite pas attendre 50 ans je
jorion rapport avez-vous vu le nombre de
lois qu'on propose d'amender je veux
dire c'est fait la loi sur la police la
charte de la langue française la grève
sur la protection de la jeunesse sur les
services correctionnels
mon dieu je veux dire ça va être encore
les batailles savait fatigué d'où
l'importance justement de la déclaration
parce que le principe de la création si
ça c'est que le qualificatif s'ajuste
aux principes qui sont avancés pour la
déclaration
c'est le défilé jeudi représente
directement gouvernement en fait c'est
ça c'est on parle puisse saper havre l'a
tellement intense mais je me dis ça mais
si on parle si on se parle de principes
de base que la déclaration ça découle de
ça et tout suis dans le même sens où ils
s'en vont en centre alors c'est alors
finalement si je résume bien il faut
appliquer rapidement l'appel à l'action
numéro 2 tout à fait pu écouter on a
déjà des gains pis ça ça mérite d'être
ici aussi on a réussi à travers des
années des familles faire modifier le
code civil la faire modifier la loi de
la protection de la jeunesse pour y
inclure le principe de l'adoption
coutumière oui et ça c'est un gain
important psy mais il faut en faire plus
ça c'est un petit morceau pile
l'assiette est beaucoup plus grand que
ça le temps passe trop vite
moi je dirais tout simplement la c5
c'est volonté politique réelle
voilà les animaux de la fin j'abonde
dans le même sens que mes collègues tout
de suite
faut pas attendre les femmes de val-d'or
elles ont besoin d'être sécurisés
maintenant et c'est ça que je veux
garder une taille pour la suite des
choses messi et piqué c'est exactement
la préoccupation numéro 1 puis je pense
que je pense quand j'en suis convaincu
que tout le monde converge assure merci
à tous les trois d'avoir participé à cet
espace autochtone en direct nous
n'allons pas arrêter de parler de du
rapport de la commission vient de ces
appels à l'action ça va être
régulièrement ramené sur le tapis au
cours des prochains mois en tout cas ici
à l'espace autochtone merci à tous les
trois je rappelle donc le nombre des
invités michel rouleau ghislain picard
isabelle picard je m'appelle anne-marie
yvan la semaine prochaine on va parler
des élections fédérales y aura eu deux
débats et isabelle entre autres sera là
pour en discuter
à très bientôt au revoir
[Musique]